no introduction
adita devaraj was a grad student working
with me until last year
and uh absolutely absolutely a star
um he was
[Music]
just a really an inspiration when it
came to started working with me
and by the way at university of illinois
for 15 years
i asked students in my stochastic
control course
to look into variants of q learning none
of them took the bait except for a
detail
and that's what actually launched this
old zap thing um
he's a university of florida informatics
institute
fellow which gave me some of his funding
he
he he got me some of my favorite gigs uh
in terms of lectures and and funding
when he was a
grad student because he was more in
demand than me when he was a grad
student as a speaker
and so forth um and now he's a post talk
with ben van roy at stanford
uh we're so learning all sorts of new
stuff and information theory and rl
so thanks sean thanks for the wonderful
introduction and also
uh thanks to uh emma mendy and you for
giving me an
opportunity to speak here um and also
all the organizers other organizers for
organizing this wonderful workshop um
so today i'll be uh talking about uh my
work on
queue learning with uniformly bonded
variants and this is based on
joint work with uh my wonderful
collaborators like shuhang
um who's just whose work you just heard
about from sean
and also my advisor sean mine and
annabeus at indriya
um so and thanks to all the funding
agencies for
sponsoring my research um and uh
nsf and ufii and also the simons
institute for
you know like uh organizing uh this sort
of workshops
uh and i i was like the beneficiary of
this
thing and back in 2018 where i enjoyed a
lot like
of my five months of my phd um
so okay let me just begin um so the
motivation for this talk
uh is this sort of uh finite and bound
that seems to be like very popular and
a lot of um recent theoretical
reinforcement learning papers
so here theta star is some sort of an
optimal parameter vector
that parameterizes your either q
function or your value function
and theta n is an estimate of this theta
star after n iterations
of running an algorithm um
gamma is a discount factor so that's a
different notation from shan's
talk so gamma is denotes a discount
factor instead of beta
um and b is some scalar uh that depends
on
the dimension of the state space action
space or the number of states
actions etc which we don't really care
about
and as i said n is the number of
hydrations so what i'm really interested
in here
is this this factor here this one over
one minus gamma to the p
and that seems to blow up as the
discount factor gamma goes closer to one
and what we really want to try to
understand is this factor necessary
uh in this
finite time bounds are is
it possible to sort of avoid it um
and here are a few examples where such a
bound appears in many
uh papers and most recently we saw
uh such bounds appeared and both martin
went right stock and also in rahul jain
stock
and and the spoiler alert is that
this sort of a factor is essentially due
to estimating a constant and thus value
function of the q
value function and ultimately this is
may not be something that you care about
and um and
in many cases we think that this can be
uh avoidable
uh so and uh and i'll show you how to do
that
okay uh so here's a basic overview of
the talk
i'll keep this discussion on sarcastic
approximation short since sean just
covered it
uh but um the rest of it is
uh just on convergence analysis of q
learning and
relative q learning algorithm which i'll
be introducing shortly
uh so first the uh problem setup uh
we'll denote
x to be the spatially controlled markov
chain uh that's evolving on a finite
state space x
and also this voltage u to be the um
input sequence or the action sequence
and that's also taking values on the
finite action space
uh we'll denote this pu to be the
transition probability matrix
that is given current action is u and
the current set is x the probability of
transiting
the state x prime is given by this over
here
and we'll denote c to be the cos
function okay and
also the gamma to be the discount factor
so given a policy feedback policy fee
will denote qfe to be the q value
function that corresponds to policy fee
and that is given by this infinite
summation over here
and this optimal q function q star is
the minimum or all policies
uh fee of q phi
okay um and it is well known that
this optimal q function q star solves a
fixed point equation known as a bellman
equation
uh so here t denotes the bellman
operator that is defined over here
and we'll also use q lower bar
to denote the minimum or all actions of
q star
so that's just some notation setup
um the goal in dynamic programming
is to find the solution q star to the
six point equation q star equal to t q
star
okay um and one way to
interpret this dynamic programming goal
is the following
let's say you have an input sequence u n
that makes sure that you visit each and
every state action pair x and u like
infinitely often then uh solving this
conditional expectation equal to 0
now for each and every n is equivalent
to solving this fixed point equation
um why am i writing it out like this so
this is the reason
so the goal in q learning can be
interpreted as sort of an approximation
to the dynamic programming goal
um so let's say you're given a
parameterized family of q functions q
theta
so your theta denotes the parameter
vector it's it's taking values in rb
the goal is to find one interpretation
of the goal
is to solve this what is known as a
projected
bellman equation where you're taking
this term inside
this conditional expectation uh you're
removing the conditioning
and then you're hitting it by a
dimensional
sequence known as the eligibility vector
which
which i'm denoting here by zeta n okay
and usually the parameterization and the
choice of zeta and as part of
algorithm design um and
and and one very popular choice of for
this eligibility vector is just
choosing it to be the gradient of the q
function which as
sean already mentioned is what
essentially is done in
dqm um
so watkins q learning or as is well
known as tabular q learning
is a very special case of uh this
solving this projected bellman equation
uh so in this uh setting uh the
parameter
is family is uh is q theta is linearly
parameterized
uh with basis function denoted to be psi
the eligibility of vectors zeta n is
essentially equal to gradient of q theta
which is equal to the basis function
itself
the number of basis functions is
actually equal to the number of state
action pairs and the basis functions are
chosen to be the indicator functions so
this is called the complete basis
setting or full basis setting
um and it's well known that this
solving this is equal to solving uh
finding the exact
q function and why is that
so if you uh choose this set of hyper
parameters the linear parameterization
and also complete basis
then this f power of theta star that is
written over here can be written in this
form
so here pi is a diagonal matrix
with each of its component uh being the
stationary distribution of this markov
chain
x u um again q theta star is the
uh q uh parameters q function that
corresponds to the optimal parameter
like
theta star and t is the bellman operator
okay so if you look at
if you let's say you solve f bar theta
star equal to zero
uh clearly if your uh if your
exploration policy is chosen in such a
way that um
the stationary distribution of x u is
non-zero for each and every x and u
uh then solving the x bar of dataset is
equal to zero is equivalent to solving
uh this bellman equation okay so that is
that should be clear from looking at
this equation here
and that's the reason the tabular
q-learning algorithm is known to solve
for the exact q function um
and so i want to make a remark here uh
so i know that not many people are
interested in tabular queue learning
algorithm
but the point here is to use it as a
sort of a vehicle to
um introduce um um
the concepts that have been that i'll be
talking about uh
but um uh essentially uh
uh like in the tabular queue learning
case like things can be made super
precise
uh and but
the ideas that i'll be talking about can
easily be extended to even function
approximation q learning or function
approximation td learning or whatever
uh so i guess that will be clear shortly
uh but i just want to remark that
tabular queue learning is not really the
goal um of our
work here okay uh so in the relative q
learning uh
algorithm the goal is to solve a
modified fixed point equation so here
t tilde let's call it the relative
bellman operator
so it's the same as the bellman operator
except that you're also subtracting of a
constant here
okay so this is part so t h star would
be just these two first two terms and t
tilde h star is
uh the first two terms minus some
constant
okay um so here this constant here
it has like two hyper parameters delta
and mu
so delta is can be like any positive
scalar uh i'll get to like how to choose
it
much later on and mu is some um
is a pmf okay and mu h star is basically
the expectation of head start with
respect to this pmf
okay and the choice of mu really doesn't
matter for the results that i'll be
talking about
um okay let's say you solve this
modified fixed point equation
um h star equal to t tilde star uh so
can we get q star
uh back from head start uh yes it's
pretty easy like it's
it's it's just offset by a constant here
um
okay so it's and that depends on delta
and mu
uh but the real question here is do we
really need q star
uh so ultimately why do we need estimate
the q value function uh
as we estimate it so that like we can
apply a greedy policy and get the
optimal policy
uh but if you look at this equation here
the optimizer for of q star is the same
as optimizer for headstart since the
constant doesn't really matter
so estimating headstar must essentially
be sufficient for you to get the optimal
policy
and this sort of analogy is true for
even um
when you apply you know td learning uh
algorithm
uh as a part of say uh actor critic or
even uh lspi kind of algorithms uh
wherein the ultimate uh
you know the use of uh this while
estimating the value function
uh is to get the next policy uh and that
you can get
even if you uh don't estimate the
constant
uh correctly so um and uh again
i'll be highlighting that again but i
guess my point here is you don't need
the constants to
in in many cases uh and in fact like
i think there are very i don't i'm not
sure where exactly you need
the constants are really important uh
you know uh
but i guess i'll leave the discussion
later on uh but
uh and the bigger question here is okay
let's say you estimate this head start
uh is there any advantage of estimating
x star instead of q star
is there any advantage of ignoring this
constant you know
um and to explain this i need to get
into a little bit of sarcastic
approximation i'll be quick since
sean already covered this um
but i'll highlight the things that that
are actually necessary for
the results that i'll be talking about
in this talk um
again this slide i'll be like super
quick since again sean just covered it
uh the goal and stochastic approximation
is to find uh theta
so f bar of thetas are equal to zero and
f bar is actually an expectation
the algorithm is dates back to robinson
and bundra in 1951
and it's given by this recursion over
here
so here i'll be assuming that
the step size alpha n is like a scalar
gain step size so alpha n is like g over
n plus one
uh in the next slide i'll be making a
comment about that uh because you just
saw shawn stock and you'll be like why
would you anybody do
a scalar step size stochastic
approximation
but i'll make a comment about that in
the next slide um
and and the way you analyze this
discrete time recursion is by looking at
this deterministic
ode and that actually is like uh
is a is foundational to proving
stability and convergence analysis of
a convergence of the stochastic
approximation algorithm
and one way to view this stochastic
approximation
recursion uh is to view it as a
noisy euler discretization of this
deterministic ode
okay and for the tabular q learning
algorithm that is like
currently of interest over in the stock
uh this noise
is essentially a martingale difference
sequence okay
um now what we're really interested in
this talk is like the convergence rate
of stochastic approximation algorithm
okay so let's denote uh theta tilde n to
be the error sequence
uh so how far away are we from theta
start after n iterations
um uh the uh the performance criteria
here
is going to be the asymptotic covariance
which is given by this limit over here
okay so clearly if if this asymptotic
covariance is finite
and then that implies a one over n
convergence rate of asymptotic
conversion state of the mean squared
error
um what the asymptotic variance theory
for stochastic approximation says is the
following
um let's denote sigma delta to be the
noise covariance matrix
uh so again delta n is a nice sequence
that appears in static approximation
algorithm
uh and a is the linearization matrix of
this uh so it's the
it's a linearization of f bar at theta
star
uh what the what the asymptotic variance
theory says is that if
you choose a step size sequence g over n
plus one in such a way that all the
eigenvalues of this matrix ga
are strictly smaller than minus half
then the asymptotic covariance is finite
and it can be obtained as a solution to
this leopardof equation over here
okay and if there exist at least one
eigenvalue
of this matrix ga that is bigger than or
equal to minus half
then the asymptotic covariance is
typically infinite
uh and again therefore the convergence
rate is
uh typically slower than one over n
which is the best convergence rate
okay um and
all the asymptotically optimal
stochastic approximation algorithms they
achieve
um asymptotic covariance
has a they have asymptotic covariance of
a inverse sigma delta inverse transpose
and some of the examples here are the
lstd lambda algorithm rupert's
stochastic newton raphson
all this averaging technique uh zap q
learning momentum etc
uh and this is a picture of rupert i
think who is responsible for at least
two of the algorithms here
and um so yeah
so the comment i want to make about this
constant substance algorithm uh
is this um so the idea the theme is
going
in this talk is going to be that we're
going to compare the best uh
scalar step size q learning algorithm
with the best scalar step size
relative q learning algorithm and
i think it will be clear when i show the
results that the performance difference
between these two algorithms
carries over when you apply say for
example averaging or
zap to q learning and relative to
learning
and that's because um essentially
again as kind of spoiler alert we'll be
changing the a matrix because we're
changing the problem
we're making going to make the
linearization matrix a a better
condition and again that should be very
clear
but again the point here is uh sure you
may not be interested in scalar gain
algorithms but even if you apply rupert
polik averaging to both q learning and
relative q learning
algorithms uh you will still observe
this performance difference that
we want to show okay
now that we have okay
ten more minutes uh so now that we have
covered the stochastic approximation
um uh convergence set of static
approximation let's apply it to q
learning
uh so firstly q learning is static
approximation that is given by this
recursion over here
uh so if you let's let's uh
uh start with the uh stupid steps is
alpha and like one over n
uh in this case the linearization matrix
a can be written in this form over here
so uh p phi star is the transition
matrix that corresponds to the optimal
policy uh
ph star um and you can show that
the maximum eigen value of this matrix a
has a real path that is
bigger than or equal to this quantity
over here
uh again this pi of x comma u is the
stationary distribution of this markov
chain
and the maximum value it can take is
like is is one
and therefore you can show that if your
discount factor gamma is
uh bigger than half uh the right hand
side
is bigger than or equal to minus half
and therefore
uh and therefore you can show that
that's important covariance is
infinity if your discount factor is
bigger than half okay
and that implies an asymptotic mean
square error convergence rate that can
be like much slower than
one over n and it's given by this
quantity over here okay
um again like i said nobody uses steps
as of
alpha and one over m uh so it's much
more common to use a step size of this
form so here
n of x comma u is number of times you
have resisted a particular state action
where x and u
i call this state action dependent step
size
in this case you can get rid of this pi
matrix that used to appear in the
previous
linearization matrix um and this is what
the linearization matrix looks like for
this algorithm
and once again the maximum eigenvalues
of this 8 matrix a
can be precisely computed to be like
minus of 1 minus gamma
and i and it's corresponds to the right
eigenvector
all once uh and in this case once again
if you
choose gamma to be bigger than half then
this like a lambda max of a is bigger
than
minus half and therefore doesn't try to
covariance is once again infinity
and once again this implies an
asymptotic mean squared convergence rate
that is slower than 1 over n
in this case but if you
scale up the step size uh by 1 minus
gamma inverse
then you can guarantee a convergence
rate of 1 over m
but what that does is it it also
scales up your asymptotic covariance
matrix by this factor 1 minus gamma to
the minus
2 which i think is essentially the
reason for all this
um such a term to appear in
all these finite time bounds so
this 1 minus gamma to the minus 2 is
essentially the reason for
1 minus gamma to the minus t that i
showed in my first
slide okay um
so let's analyze uh let's do a similar
analysis or relative q learning
algorithm
uh so this is the main contribution of
this work
so let's look at the linearization
matrix for relative q learning it's
essentially the same as the one for
q learning algorithm except that you're
also
adding a rank one uh matrix over here uh
and that that can be like super helpful
and i'll show you how
uh so firstly uh the eigenvalue that
corresponds to
the right eigenvector one uh which was
earlier minus of one minus gamma
now it is minus of 1 minus gamma plus
delta okay and delta is the degree of
freedom that you can choose and you can
always make sure that
by choosing a delta large enough you can
make sure that this is
very small okay and
all the other eigen values are uh have
real parts that are
uh sickly bonded away from minus of one
minus gamma
rho star uh here rho star is um
is a scalar that is defined over here uh
you can think of it as like
um sort of a if you're uh if you if your
problem has a finite mixing time then
row star is always smaller than one
uh and even if uh your the the mixing
rate rho is like
equal to one you can show that roster
can be smaller than one
so this is something that is problem
dependent rho star
uh and so and if
you choose a step size of this form okay
earlier it was minus of one minus gamma
inverse
inverse and now if you choose the steps
of this form you can guarantee a finite
asymptotic
variance and and therefore the
asymptotic variance will be proportional
to
um this quantity over here uh instead of
1 minus gamma to the minus two so this
may not look like a very big
improvement uh but the point here is no
matter how big your discount factor is
gamma is
uh if your uh the problem that you're
looking at is has like finite mixing
time
uh then uh uh then the slowstar is
always strictly smaller than
one uh and therefore like this is always
bounded away from
like uh this is always like if it's a
finite quantity with respect to how
gamma is
closer to one okay um and that can be
like uh
a big improvement uh at least in in many
examples
okay um and uh
so here is a basic basically one slide
summary of
the what relative q learning algorithm
is essentially doing
um so this basically summarizes
all my previous slides so here a pc star
is a
a transition probability matrix that
corresponds to the optimal policy phase
start
okay um and uh there's one eigen value
at
one and all the other eigen values are
uh have
real parts that are strictly smaller
than one but there are two more eigen
values that have
um that are on the unit circle but have
real parts smaller than one
uh the eigenvalues of this matrix aq so
aq's linearization matrix for the q
learning algorithm
are essentially a scaled and shifted
version of these eigenvalues over here
and you see that this lambda
equal to one uh eigenvalue becomes a
problematic eigenvalue of the
linearization matrix so remember you
want all the eigenvalues to be bounded
uh should be to be strictly smaller than
minus half the real part should be
smaller than minus half to have finite
asymptotic
variance but uh there is one eigenvalue
at minus of 1 minus gamma
and to get rid of this minus of 1 minus
gamma eigen value what you do is you
multiply this by 1 minus gamma inverse
and that becomes -1
so that's the minimum scalar that you
have to multiply this linearization
matrix to
get finite asymptotic variance
and what you're doing in this relative q
learning algorithm is essentially you're
taking this bad eigenvalue
and then you're moving it somewhere
inside and it would be really cool if
you could do that in very in in general
but this
becomes very easy uh in table's actual
learning algorithm
and um and now the the the problematic
are they not so problematic anymore but
the most problematic eigen values are
uh uh corresponding to the eigenvalues
that have the
second largest real parts that
correspond to these two eigen values
here
and these are always bounded away from
uh the right half plane
no matter what discount factor gamma you
choose
okay and hence the title uniformly
bonded
variances okay
um so how does this perform uh so here
what i'm plotting is like
i'm plotting uh three different q
learning algorithms
first is a q learning algorithm with
optimize optimal step size
that is one over one minus gamma uh that
is necessary for
a finite asymptotic variance and one
over n convergence rate
and i'm also plotting a q learning
algorithm with
the step size that is optimal for the
relative q learning algorithm
and um and i'm also implementing the
relative q learning algorithm
and what i'm plotting here is i'm
choosing two different discount factors
they're pretty large 0.999 and 0.9999
and when i implement the relative q
learning algorithm i complete the
relative q value function and i showed
that it has a direct mapping to the q
function and then i get the q function
from that
uh and i'm plotting the maximal bellman
error for each of these three algorithms
okay um and you see that
for the discount factor is 0.999 the
the q learning algorithm with optimal
step size um
it does go close to zero but it's like
very very nicey
uh and if you make it discount factor
even bigger uh then it becomes even more
noisy
but the relative q learning algorithm
seems to be like sort of you know
have an unchanged behavior here and if
you don't choose the step size to be big
enough then you will see that the
the q learning algorithm like takes
forever to converge to zero
um and uh again
you should guess that this should be due
to a constant and
that's what we kind of show next uh so a
small twist in the tail towards the end
of the talk
um i won't take long um but this is
another result that we showed in the
paper
uh so what we show is we just uh
showed that the eigenvalue that
corresponds to the right eigenvector one
is minus of one minus gamma plus delta
for relative q learning and minus of one
minus gamma for
q learning algorithm uh so what we show
is all the other eigen values of these
two matrices are exactly the same
okay and if you choose any
d dimensional vectors v and w that are
orthogonal to this all once
vector then uh this v dagger sigma
infinity theta w where sigma infinity
theta again recall as the asymptotic
variance
is the same for both q learning and
relative learning algorithms
and this is true only if you use the
same step size for both the algorithms
okay so what this essentially means
is that the convergence set of the two
algorithms is exactly the same
except in the subspace corresponding to
the basis function okay and this is true
again only if you use
the same step size for the both both
algorithms okay if you pretend
that if you want to use g equal to one
over one minus gamma for the q learning
algorithm and it's a different
uh one one over one minus gamma rho star
for
uh relative algorithm then this is not
true uh hold anymore
okay and fair enough so if you plot the
span norm
of the uh of the q function estimate
uh minus the optimal q function q start
uh this is what it looks like the
uh the q learning algorithm with optimal
step size is still bad
but the q learning algorithm with this
step set that is optimal for relative q
learning algorithm
does uh almost exactly similar to the
relative q learning algorithm
when you look at the span knob so and uh
and that that i guess was like sort of a
in some sense surprising but can also in
some sense kind of obvious result that
we found
okay uh but does this property extend
beyond tabular setting and
i don't think so uh and uh
yeah because i think there's a sort of a
correlation between the parameters of uh
constants and
other basis functions so in conclusion
we use asymptotic theory of stochastic
approximation
to design and analyze relative q
learning algorithm
it seems to be that the most of the
complexity in classical queue learning
seems to be spent on estimating this
constant that you may not care about
because ultimately all you want is the
policy uh keeping everything relative
doesn't really hurt the relative q
learning algorithm results in asymptotic
variance that is like uniformly bonded
for r discount factor smaller than one
um it also gives us the q function uh
by just adding a constant but i guess we
don't really need it
and similar sort of analogy holds for td
learning algorithms when used as a part
of factor critic or
lspi algorithms
and once again the algorithm can be
zapped but the difference is the
linearization matrix a h
is much better condition for the
relative q learning algorithm and
than for uh the q learning algorithm uh
and you can also get a globally stable
relative q learning algorithm similar to
using techniques that sean already
mentioned
uh you can apply averaging acceleration
vary introduction all these techniques
to even relative to learning algorithm
and uh the performance improvement will
be the same
and the next question is like the open
problem can we get a finite time
analysis
of relative q learning algorithm and can
we extend this theory to
episodic reinforcement learning and
so here are a list of references and
thank you yeah
great great uh that's
it that's the old friend he's doing fine
don't worry
[Laughter]
so i guess so i don't see any questions
in there
um yeah i think
i think it's yeah i think it's i think
we'll just have uh different questions
till later
unless there's any quick ones but i
don't see it yeah i'll stop this shirt
yeah
okay thank you very much um i have a
quick question